il ya trois secteurs importants dans la
société israélienne aujourd'hui qui
sociologiquement penche à droite c'est
les milieux disons populaire sépharade
qui sont fidèles au likoud est assez au
parti shass qui est un parti ultra
orthodoxe qui est un petit peu qui sont
clairement du côté du côté de la droite
il y a ensuite les les ultra orthodoxes
qui certes ne sont pas ne sont pas
engagés politiquement dans un activisme
messianique comme les sionistes
religieux c'est important à dire et qui
politiquement ça ni à la droite depuis
depuis très longtemps est enfin il ya
les juifs originaires de l'ancienne
union soviétique qui la différence de
des ultra orthodoxes ou même des
sionistes religieux ne sont pas
religieux sont vraiment sont vraiment
laïque de façon écrasante mais sont en
même temps nationaliste et donc se
retrouve là aussi je dirais du côté de
la droite donc si vous prenez en compte
ces trois groupes sociologie qui
constitue la société d'aujourd'hui pas
c'est pas les seuls évidemment mais ces
trois groupes importants
démographiquement également eh bien vous
comprenez très bien que l'électorat
allemand y soit il soit dominant est que
depuis 2001 il n'y a plus un premier
ministre qui était issu de la gauche
même si longtemps au sens relativement
large du terme qu'à l'issue du parti
travailliste a donc ça c'est une réalité
et netanyahu que par état est une sorte
d'incarnation de ceux de ce phénomène si
c'était pas netanyahou ce serait
quelqu'un d'autre évidemment il peut
avoir des talents entre nîmes et
politiques qui lui sont propres mais il
est quand même le représentant d'une
tendance qui est qui qui le dépassent
très largement et donc quelque part il
est l'incarnation
[Musique]